ينضم إلي ماك رذرفورد الآن للحديث
عن هذا الإنجاز المذهل.
تهانينا ، إنه لأمر
رائع أن أراك
آه ، يجب أن أسألك أولاً عن شعورك ،
أعني أنه قد مرت بضعة أيام
حتى تستقر هذه الرحلة المحطمة للأرقام القياسية
عندما أقلعت  في مارس ، هل كنت
تعتقد حقًا أنك ستكون قادرًا على الطيران
بمفردك حول العالم
أه جيدًا ، لذلك كان من
الصعب جدًا تخيل
الأمر مع هذه الرحلة ، لقد
أخذتها خطوة بخطوة لم أكن كذلك
أفكر ، في غضون شهرين ، سأنتهي ،
كنت أفكر غدًا أنني يجب أن أكون في
صقلية ، سأكون في جزيرة كريت ، هذا نوع
من الطريقة التي يجب عليك التعامل
معها ولكن بالتأكيد كانت هناك العديد من النقاط
في رحلتي حيث كان من الصعب
جدًا  تخيلني في الواقع أنني قادر على
إنهاء رحلتي ، نعم أخبرني عن
بعض تلك اللحظات بعد ذلك لأنه
كانت هناك بعض المواقف المشعرة التي
واجهتها والتي قرأت عنها
والتي أجبرتك على النوم على مدرج في
جزيرة غير مأهولة في المحيط الهادئ
ماذا  هابي  نيد
أم نعم ، لذلك عندما كنت أسافر من
اليابان إلى الولايات المتحدة ، كان علي أن أقوم برحلة طويلة جدًا لمدة
10 ساعات لأنني لم أستطع الطيران
عبر روسيا ،
لذلك أقلعت من اليابان ،
وبعد 10 ساعات طرت فوق البئر الذي طرت فيه  فوق
المحيط الهادئ
وبعد 10 ساعات وصلت إلى
جزيرة أتو وهي جزيرة صغيرة غير
مأهولة في شمال
المحيط الهادئ ، وقد بدأت في أن تصبح
مظلمة تمامًا وكان هناك غيوم منخفضة كانت
تمطر ، قلت إن الطقس العام
لم يكن  لم يكن لطيفًا جدًا
لكنني تمكنت من الهبوط وعلى
جانب المدرج رأيت هذه السقيفة
الصغيرة وأوقفت بجانبها وبقيت هناك
طوال الليل لأنه لا يوجد
مكان آخر أقيم
فيه وهكذا كان ذلك  حقًا
تجربة خاصة مختلفة تمامًا عن
أي شيء مررت به من قبل
ولكن بعد ذلك في اليوم التالي استيقظت
نظرت حول الجزيرة قليلاً
كانت جزيرة جميلة جدًا ثم واصلت
رحلتي بإطلالة
لقد أنجزت الكثير  يجب أن أقول أكثر
من معظم الأشخاص الذين تتراوح أعمارهم بين 17 و 70
عامًا  ما هي الخطوة التالية ، ما الذي تأمل
أن تفعله في المستقبل
بشكل جيد جدًا في المستقبل القريب
العودة إلى المدرسة حتى تبدأ المدرسة في
غضون أسبوع تقريبًا ، لذا ليس هناك الكثير من الوقت
للراحة على الإطلاق
، وعليك فقط محاولة
اللحاق بما يلي  قدر الإمكان لأنني
فاتني قدرًا كبيرًا من المدرسة في الأشهر الخمسة لي ،
نعم أراهن